so this is a tall order
for the 23 year old venezuelan
his fastball 91-96 this season it had to
be a little bit frustrating for springer
in game one came up with the bases
loaded once came up with a man on first
once and both times hit the ball pretty
hard he just happened to hit it right to
the third baseman jack mayfield
two on the way and springer's on that
one lines it to left and it is over the
head of lagarus and off the wall on a
bounce and a good start springer aboard
with a lead off double let's see if
vladimir guerrero can get it going
suarez deals and the first pitch is
looped in the air shallow and center
down for a base hit springer cuts the
bag at third eaton's up with a throw
from right springer with a head first
slide he's in there he's safe and the
blue jays
near pitches into the ball game have a
one-nothing lead 2-2
and
oscar pops it up shallow right field and
that's going to drop
and guerrero reading it well comes
around to score
he picked it up he thought it would drop
he took off and he scores on a blue
barbie single by tay oscar hernandez and
the blue jays lead two to nothing
and he wasn't squared up it wasn't hit
on the barrel and watch him react he
looks at eden and knows he's not going
to make the catch and challenges adam
eaton who at one time had a terrific arm
he wasn't very deep in right field
but guerrero got a good jump and slides
across home ahead of the throw
[Applause]
get firm
out
to first out there
angels turn a double play blue jays get
two
yeah ralph strippling as we mentioned
has pitched very well in his last three
starts and he's made some great
adjustments over the course of the
season and
last time out stripling had a very good
change up he was just
terrific with that change if he could
throw it for a swing and a miss he could
throw it for a cold strike
joe man has done this before with ohtani
he's three for 12 with a home run
when hitting lead off
now tony
into the corner and after the race as he
goes
hernandez into the corner tommy's
thinking three digging around second
by surprise a little bit of a bobble he
was surprised he went to go to third but
showing that speed fifth
triple
of the year
for shohei ohtani
[Applause]
one of those strides but he's think he's
got something an opportunity to triple
then his turns on the afterburner and
all of a sudden how quick he gets from
second to third slides in with the
triple
and now fletcher sends a fly ball to
shallow right and the catch made by tay
oscar and a good throw too ohtani wasn't
going to test the arm that's out number
one
the 2-1 lined up the middle speared by
simeon caught on the backhand on a line
and the 2-1
good change up and it's popped up
and what a job by ross stripling
leadoff triple by ohtani and he pitches
his way out of it so marsh recognizing
that he's the third with two down for
kurt suzuki but they found a way
0-2 fastball in the air to right field
to oscar hernandez and another runner is
left on at third two to nothing blue
jays at the end of two
chopped off the plate fletch has to wait
bare hand fire
safe
there's a lot closer than i thought
[Applause]
see how quick he's been getting down the
line running much better
very close play that they might even
take a look at
you know what
they might got her
this is a palm ball fled through and
they are going to challenge the angels
are
yeah i think he got him
this angle is a little bit better see if
that baseball is in the glove before the
foot and he is out on that he's out
nicely done
the cat
the oscar
that's a fair ball behind the bag
mayfield crossed the diamond in time
and the 3-1
mayfield spears it flips it and gets the
out suarez has settled into the game
after those two runs in the first
trevor richards back on the mound for
the home half of the fourth inning and
that's because we saw ross stripling
leave the ball game earlier with what
the team is telling me is left abdominal
discomfort stripling went two innings
and threw just 28 pitches so he is out
of the ball game with an abdominal
discomfort issue tough way to end his
night
two balls and two strikes
the pitch
swinging a miss got him with a change up
rudder was going doesn't matter marsh
goes into the glove couple of strikeouts
in the fourth issue to walk no damage
off to the fifth blue jays combining for
a
one hit shutout of the angels
wow
finishes in with a gorgeous
changeup
wow
dad junior
breaks the bat tosses the helmet
and suarez two gorgeous pitches to get
springer
[Applause]
and then vlad jr
still two nothing
go back inside with it
[Music]
and strike three called right at the
knees ohtani says it was inside very
politely but what a job by adam simmer
[Applause]
shoots it into right field his first hit
of the night
and now tay oscar lines one into left
field to base hit
the shed up to second back-to-back
singles for the blue jays
takes it outside and that's going to
load him up
quijana now has got to deal with her to
scurry out
[Music]
[Applause]
and guerrielle was ready as he lines it
into left center a base hit
the shed in to score to oscar right
behind him kirk up to second and a big
two-run single for guriel
the pitch
hit hard on the left side diving stop
made by espinal pops up throws to first
dig by bloody to get the out
and glady has become a terrific first
baseman in a short period of time this
looks like he was going to skip past
espanol into left field
sure it happens flatty but it's no
problem
espinal quick to his left gets up to his
feet and throws but kind of
handcuffs vladi a little bit with a
short throw and vladi is able to dig it
out good work on both ends of that
problem
base is filled with angels and here
comes ohtani
[Applause]
got it
blew it by him at 99
and the blue jays will win it